hello everyone how's everybody doing
I hope you're doing fine I'm doing okay
my age get I get arthritis
and that's what I have and that's what I
have to deal with anyways uh when I say
that first we put out the book known as
the Rope hypothesis you can go and check
it out a rope hypothesis calm you can
download it it's 160 page book for free
you can look at it and come up to speed
on the rope model of light and gravity
and for those who have a second language
and are good at it you know we encourage
you to contact us talk Akaka dot mil
hotmail.com that if you want to
translate it into your other mother
tongue or whatever okay so if you're
good at translating something some into
some language please contact us and we
had a couple people one one is already
apparently translating it to Hungarian
another one into Indonesian so you're
now translating into Spanish so maybe
we'll get this book all over the world
anyways the other thing I want to
mention again is that we have a
conference coming up in Lusaka Zambia
and it's hosted by my friend
Shamu mcoms
and Seamus I can't shovel and so you
know beg borrow and steal and see if you
can make it because it's gonna be maybe
a trip of a lifetime okay or the
adventure of a lifetime
I hear there's beer down there so I'm
gonna try it anyways uh getting back to
our subject manner
the other day I left off and I mentioned
in passing some nouns that we have in
physics it was in mathematical physics
really and you will see a list here this
is just an impromptu list off the top of
my head
where's like orbit energy mass
trajectory you know we consider those
nouns in ordinary speech and
mathematicians use them in their
language in in their mathematical
language they use these words as well
and and so what I want to say is that
these are not nouns for the purposes of
physics the way we look at it in
rational physics although these are
verbs that's why they're in green
instead of brown those are the colors I
chose to separate nouns for verbs
here's another list similar these are
these are words that are not verbs but
there are concepts some kind of concept
either static or whatever
typically static concepts in this case
and again they're treated as nouns
people use them as the subject of a
sentence and that's not allowed in
rational physics okay and what's the
problem one of the big problems with
this is that people tend to apply the
wrong adjective or the wrong adverb they
apply adverbs they end up applying
adverbs to nouns and adjectives to verbs
that's what we end up having so you know
people talk about infinite motion or or
constant but could it be a constant
orbit or whatever and you know you can't
do that you you you you got to use these
words consistently right and you can't
mix them around and so this is uh this
is a serious problem today because you
know you wonder how we got to general
relativity saying that
time dilates and you say what do you
mean time dilates well the time is not a
physical objects not a noun
only objects can serve as nouns in
rational physics and for someone to say
that you know time dilates that you're
or that gravity bends time or warps time
or that I transfer energy you know these
terms are all irrational and all that
language has got to go all that in
mathematical physics language is no good
so that's one of the issues a major
issue people say bill you're doing
semantics you're boring me with us
unfortunately we have to bore you you
need to understand the language because
that's when people get run into trouble
and I have an example a good example
today someone wrote a comment and I
thought that comment needed to be
highlight brought in so that people can
see how this new language that we're
proposing and rational physics rational
science is applied ok and here's the
case person put this comment in there
yeah and he says the lines of force are
real ok we can see and feel it I don't
think you can see or feel the lines of
force right the people the the net
appeal but the entities that have some
kind of inter relation with them or the
iron filings we can see those but we
can't see the lines of force that compel
iron filings to line up in certain
patterns how can it not exist it is
certainly not physical but it's real
it's not physical but it's real ok is it
so heretic to have this notion that
something non-physical actually exists
men continue says if yes we are denying
the existence of what light our homes
and power our motors
electricity and so you know I think what
what's happening here is this fellas
chasing his tail around because he he
doesn't define his terms
so what we do is we define them and then
we know what we're saying what we're
talking about and we define first
physical the word physical that he uses
as that which has shape that's physical
yeah so that's the definition we use for
the word physical that exists becomes
anything that has that is physical it
has to be physical can't be a concept
it's got to be an object okay it's gotta
have shape which is the only criterion
for physical and then it's gotta have
also location the set of distances to
all other objects in the universe now we
can use the word exist and physical
consistently and we don't get into this
this runaround this fella had what I
call dog chasing his tailed around
that's what he did okay so yeah I hope
he stops chasing his tail around and
follows you know a little bit of
semantics that we proposed so that we
can apply it to analyzing what he's
trying to say there because he goes back
and forth he says you know first he says
he we can see and feel it and we're
saying as you can see on the bottom
right we don't use the senses at all
so anything related to senses has
nothing to do with the word object or
with the word exists the word exists has
to do with physical presence it only has
to have location we do not need to touch
it or see it or smell it or taste it or
whatever okay we can't taste light we
can't smell gravity okay
so anyone who thinks that they're gonna
zero in on the causes of gravity by you
know by applying the senses is mistaken
these are invisible intangible things
the mediators the mediator of gravity is
invisible intangible so you can't go to
the lab and say I'm gonna run an
experiment to find out what gravity is
yeah well the way you do it you sit back
you have a motto maybe like I do you
know you sit back and you think you try
to visualize then you can figure it out
because that's all you need to do you
need to figure out what invisible
mediators mother nature father universe
God whoever out there you know is using
to do gravity light magnetism etc all
the invisible stuff in the universe
that's all we have to do once we figure
that out we're done with physics because
now we can see the universe we can
visualize the universe okay maybe not
see it but visualize it in our minds
okay and so yeah we we have a little bit
of a problem with the language that's
where it starts and see you put this up
here this is then a reply to him and
that's what people want to really
understand try to get to the bottom of
what are those lines of force well with
sprinkle iron filings over magnets and
they'd be these these patterns that we
see there okay and the question is uh
there's something out there that we
can't touch we can't see we can't smell
we can't taste that is moving these iron
filings around immediately it's this
light snap right there you know you
instantly they they form run these
patterns around the magnets and you can
see that they form specific patterns you
label them as concave and convex in the
book okay these are pictures from the
book and and they have to be real in the
sense that you know they cause effects
in the physical world and you can see
that at the bottom right
that's a solenoid or a coil bed spring
whatever you want to call it and it's a
live one and you can see the lines of
force going around okay so they're
they're circling the entire coil okay in
a circle in specific ways just like the
magnet above it if we were to place the
magnet it on top of that coil it would
happen exactly the same pattern
in other words what you're staring at at
the bottom right which is a coil is also
a magnet okay and and the lines of force
had better be real because they cause a
force right through the center of the
coil and it also has its north and south
and so what is that force I mean are we
gonna put spirits in there are we gonna
do with angels were like the Thomas
Aquinas did you know what's going on
there well what is that invisible stuff
and if you say there's nothing there
because you can't see it or touch it
then in effect you're putting spirits in
that saying you're doing black magic
you're doing voodoo magic here you're
saying no there's nothing there but
suddenly that nothingness those angels
those spirits whatever you call those
that X that's pushing things through
there it's causing a force and you're
saying that's caused by nothing there's
nothing there just because you can't see
or touch it and that's when you have to
define the word object not as that which
you can touch or see smell taste here
right you have to define as that which
has shaped which is the only property
all objects in the universe have and the
word object is a synonym of the word
physical so they're both synonyms as far
as we're concerned and that which is
physical is not that which you can touch
or see like in ordinary speech in
rational Sciences it's that which has
shape and there's something that has
shape in there or like James Maxwell
said in that space talking about a
magnetic field he said there's matter in
motion some kind of exotic matter that
can't be touched or seen and it's in
motion in there it has an effect on a
real world and we said well we can't see
it or touch it yeah you can't because
that's not the definition of what an
object is shape is what characterizes an
object and until you get that in your
head and a lot of trouble especially
within this channel okay okay so
where does this take us well takes us to
the subject matter today which is mr.
Aristotle and mr. Euclid and they lived
about 2,000 plus years ago and what one
of them you know is not all he tried to
do physics he tried to do fit not that
he did but he tried to do physics what
he did was define the word physics a and
this is what he was up to he's trying to
lay the foundations of physics and he is
nouns such as you know stand still or at
rest
location distance these are the nouns
that he's going to use today and he's
going to talk about motion time and
number none of which qualify as nouns
for the purposes of rational physics but
this is the starting point one and
second this is what the mathematicians
today have inherited from Airy ok so
good old Airy use these nouns then he
use these qualifiers these adjectives
and again you can see that he if those
are not nouns because they are either
dynamic or static concepts then these
become in Congress because now you're
applying an adjective to that which is
not physical to that which is not a noun
to that which is not an object
ok so now you're talking about an
infinite motion or for example or
whatever in between two numbers you know
you can't use those terms in physics
there's no physical object called number
and then you cannot talk about something
being between two numbers not in physics
in ordinary speech and mathematics yeah
you can say all that but not in physics
okay because you're no longer using
objects physics is mediated by objects
you can say between the table and the
chair but you cannot say between two
between energy and mass that for example
right so this is the issue the issue is
you got to be very careful with the
language because we're gonna spoil all
this stuff and you want
get the the good thing about it once you
master the language and you say whatever
paragraph you read out there from
ordinary people from high-level people
it doesn't matter you read it and say
well what is the noun
well the noun is the object what is the
object in the sun's not the now not the
not not the noun or the the thing you're
gonna talk about but what is the real
object here the thing and when you start
looking at then you say what words the
verb where's the adverb where's the
adjective then you start realizing how
people how the ordinary speech cannot be
translated directly into physics okay
and in contrast to him we have this
other fellow and his name was Euclid and
for sure we call him uke and you could
you know he dealt with other kinds of
now because he was trying to do geometry
he was around lay the foundations of
mathematics that's a little differently
a little different and his nouns you
know he used words like point line plane
solid and also number because he's gonna
do things with numbers right and the
qualifiers he uses are things like angle
perpendicular parallel mister Nell their
center edge you know those these are the
words he's going to use so these two
fellows are going to use two different
languages and you have to remember that
the guy who defines the word physics is
Aristotle now maybe this word was used
earlier than that physics just means
nature that's related to the word nature
so it's like the study of nature that
sort of thing and he's the guy who
defines physics the word physics and
he's gonna apply it more or less like me
he's gonna try to get to the foundations
he's trying to figure out how this
universe works and that's not what
Euclid's gonna do it
Euclid's gonna set the foundations for
geometry and before we can get there
it's important to try to put this in the
right historical context which is what I
want to do today as a starting point
there will be an introduction to
geometry - it comes later but
but what I want you to note is how this
developed bestia and it's and it's
starting point which was around the time
of Aristotle and you it really started
earlier these two individuals inherited
a lot of this they developed it a little
more perhaps they put the you know they
had their inputs into this but
essentially they inherited a lot of that
from maybe 200 300 years of people like
collies and Pythagoras and so on who
develop a lot of stuff and pass it on
from generation to generation by the
time it arrives at the 4th century BC
which is when these folks lived beast
Aristotle and 3rd century is Euclid is
credited we don't know when he was born
when when he was when he died yeah we
know a little more about Aristotle even
though you came a little later but let's
put him in the proper context and here's
the little map so that you can get a
feel for where these guys lived and what
they did
Athens was the center of of the world in
those days around three four hundred
years BC until the Romans finally you
know conquered them and Aristotle was
not an Athenian he was not from southern
Greece he was from northern part he was
a Macedonian
okay and he was he studied with Plato
who had set up his Academy in Athens in
fact north of Athens he was outside of
the city limits that's where the academy
was north and Aristotle studied there
for 20 years until Plato died when Plato
died Aristotle goes back I guess the
stage era where he was from or perhaps
directly to where he was going to go
next which is Pella which was the
capital of the Macedonian Empire which
had just started Philip the second
Alexander the Great's father he called
Aristotle to be the tutor of Alexander
and that's what his job would be for the
next couple years
and by this time you know Euclid
probably wasn't even born because uh
Alexander eventually goes out and
conquers Persia and before it does he
obviously has to get rid of his dad and
apparently that was a you know something
that you know happened one of those lone
gunmen type of crimes someone killed
Phillip and more than likely it was
orchestrated by Alexander's mother
why because Phillip had taken a new
bride had a graboid with him with her
and this other fella kills Phillip and
then they kill him immediately
so dead men till tell no tales sort of
thing and that's how Alexander becomes
King as soon as he becomes king since
Aristotle was his friend and educator
his tutor right
his professor Aristotle goes back to
Athens but this time he doesn't go to
the Academy to Plato's Academy because
he didn't really like a lot of the ideas
coming out of Plato and instead he goes
and to the Lyceum the Lyceum already
existed people gathered there
philosophers soldiers vendors everybody
gathered around the Lyceum and the four
officer first met there and now that
Alexander is the head of the entire
Greek Empire right
he sends Aristotle there Aristotle puts
his headquarters at the Lyceum he
teaches there and he has a lot of
students and that's why one of the
issues that comes up today is whether he
came up with all these ideas or this was
a collective effort
maybe maybe Aristotle was giving
lectures and his students took notes and
maybe those are the notes we get today
it's very hard to know exactly how this
all his book called physics got
assembled but we give him credit and I
guess in the end it's irrelevant the
important things what he says in the
book yeah
now it turns out that you know he was
there for like 10 11 years and then
Alexander gets murdered and yeah I mean
you know another case there because FST
in his right hand man he died a few
months earlier in mysterious
circumstances he got sick all of a
sudden you know probably poisoned and I
think that's the same thing happened to
Alexander few months later they got rid
of them and because he was getting rid
of a couple of the generals and the
general just took over the Empire and
debated ended up so that's in a nutshell
what happened well when when news
reaches Greece that Alexander was dead
aris thought it was in a little bit of a
trouble because he was a Macedonian in
Athens he was not a citizen of Athens
and citizen city city-state citizenship
was very important it was like you know
you're in a different country so to
speak and so Aristotle is there he's got
a run for his life kind of thing you
know he realizes his situation he leaves
Athens you know maybe he's he was to
some degree the eyes and ears of the
Macedonians in Athens he's got to leave
he noses so he leaves and you know it's
very you know he dies about a year later
so again maybe he was murdered for all I
know you know who knows but the point is
he leaves and and that's the end of
century of the formal Lyceum later on
continues a few more years to the third
century I think to the 280 250 before
that before Christ and finally you know
just dwindles into nothing finally it's
destroyed by the Romans many years later
and so this is the story for that and
the question is now where does Euclid
come into this well Euclid is one
generation right after Aristotle
he's one generation later he's like 20
years younger than Aristotle at least
and he studied with the students of
Plato which which were at the same age
level as Aristotle so he
comes later and in fact he goes to
Alexandria to the city north of Africa
in Egypt let me put that up again he's
right there in Alexandria he goes there
and you know Alexander's founded by
Alexander in round 330 331 BC so he goes
there like ten years later you could go
there about ten years later and he's
brought in there probably by Ptolemy
okay Ptolemy was the one of the generals
that took over the Empire and he took
over the area known as Egypt last of his
dynasty would be Cleopatra many years
later and he probably brought Euclid
over he probably realized that Euclid
was a smart mathematician you know I
probably have some use for you and
Ptolemy himself you know who was into a
strong and all this other stuff as well
you know he liked science and the arts
and so he brought him over and so the
issue is that Euclid probably studied at
nah I don't think he studied at the
Academy I don't know if it was open at
that time but he certainly studied at
the Lyceum war or got to know Aristotle
if he lived in the same period of time
because that stuff that was the
University of Athens essentially okay
and all the smart people all the people
rich people and rich kids who wanted to
get educated they would go into the
Lyceum and get educated so so Euclid was
very familiar with at least the ideas
that Aristotle put forth and he's going
to use a phrase that he's going to
include in his book elements which is
that which has no part referring to the
point and we find that in physics as
well yeah Aristotle's physics he already
mentions that which has no part and it's
like you CLE just took that and with him
so I have to suspect that you could
really studied in the Lyceum or at least
was very familiar with the Lyceum he
probably went there every day
whatever okay anyways so again Euclid
does mathematics and Aristotle tries to
apply all these concepts to physics what
he understood to be physics and one of
the things that he introduces again
things such as distance time motion he
these abstractions but all related to
how the universe works that's not what
Euclid does he applies it to geometry to
planes and solids especially he analyzes
that in quite a bit of detail in his
book elements okay so here we see how
they each apply it here we have
Aristotle he's trying to he's looking at
distance okay he's not interested in
using geometry as per se okay so he's
just trying to look at things like
distance motion etc and actually this is
really more like motion okay because
he's looking at you know how things move
between his hands you know he's trying
to analyze that and obviously when when
he analyzes that he gets to not only
distance which is really distance
traveled measurement he gets into motion
and he gets into time he says oh that
takes so much time and what's in between
these two ball of these two balls any
two balls that you selected dots or
whatever you want to call them so so he
gets into these kinds of analysis in his
book physics he wants to get to the
bottom of what is distance what is
motion and what is time there was a so
he has to introduce terms such as
continuous okay that's that's and in
between he these are important terms for
him because he's trying to he's trying
to define them which is good I think it
was good you only probably applied it to
concepts he didn't applied to physics
and that's that's I think where he
failed but I think he had the right
intention and again he's the first guy
who starts us all and you can expect
anyone who starts simply to make many
errors and I think he set physics on the
wrong path
from that point of view but at least he
tried he I think he at least was very
interested in in getting to the bottom
of things
and here's Euclid in comparison you know
what does he look at well he looks at
triangles so he's not looking at you
know distance per se
he was analyzed angles and you know
relations between the sides and etc okay
that's what geometry becomes so what
happens next well area applies his so
called distance time and motion but this
time he's gonna replace it with a line
okay so he's gonna use the word line he
is gonna use that okay and that's not
what you Clinton it's gonna apply it to
you Cleese gonna apply the line to his
you know to the edges of a plane for
example a triangle or a square or maybe
even the circumference of a circle okay
area what he does nice is he turns them
into points okay because he says look we
have all these motions of something from
one hand to the other and we chop them
up in locations and we're gonna put a
point in each one of those locations so
he's thinking of in terms of motion this
is what he's trying to analyze in his
book he must analyze you know location
distance traveled motion and time what
is you could gonna apply it well he's
gonna apply the same thing he's gonna
say look we're gonna turn this line into
a bunch of thoughts and the line is made
of points okay and then the question was
you know the issue of continuity and
whether they were you know they were
continuous or whether they were one
right after another in the sense that's
excessive right like if something was
flowing but that was more in turn that
Aristotle applied more than Euclid and
yeah what they're gonna do first that
area he's gonna replace that with no
so so the location becomes a number and
so now we're talking about numbers
rather than about physical things he's
gonna try to see if he can he constantly
introduces the term unit referring to
numbers and saying you know there's like
a space between two units like what is
between a1 and a2 whether if they're
integers well there's nothing in between
there yeah it's like if these are just
integers there's nothing between a1 and
a2 so he uses arguments of that nature
to show that there is under some
circumstances discontinuity okay and
Euclid's also gonna replace them you
know with numbers he's gonna be dealing
in geometry he's gonna introduce numbers
and he's gonna replace the locations
first with a dot which he calls a point
it's a zero dimensional no volume point
and that point really represents a
number okay that's what it is and so
this is the starting point for for
Humanity essentially or for the Western
world at least us we got our start in
so-called physics and mathematics and
it's interesting how Aristotle
eventually ends up defining what he
means by physics because this is this is
an important point because if the
mathematicians today have changed that
well they should call whatever they do
something different not visits because
they're not doing physics not according
to how Airy Aristotle you know
originated it and these are the notions
that Aristotle had in mind when he
created physics he says what does
physics deal with and he says it deals
with of things that exist
I like that first statement things that
exists yeah totally an agreement and
that's not what mathematical physics
deals with they don't deal with things
at all let alone things that exist they
talk about space-time and they talk
about particles and you say well a
particle that's a thing that exists
right no because a particle is a
vibrating field or a bundle of energy
what is a field what is energy a concept
so they're not dealing with things at
all so that's important to note
that's how Aristotle started but we
change that you know in other words of
mathema mathematical physicists change
that because they said look we don't
deal with things because we can't deal
with things we can't explain how mother
nature runs her universe with things the
only way we can what we can do is
describe and under way we describe with
with numbers that's the language you got
to learn if you want to learn so called
physics and what they mean by that is
mathematical physics and not physics
physics is this what Aristotle laid down
he says of things that exist that's
perfect definition for physics and he
says some exist by nature and some from
other causes okay again he's talking
about causes and he's thinking I'm sure
mechanisms that's what he had in the
back of his mind which is what we're
about okay and then he tries to define
what he means by nature he says one
account of nature is the immediate
material substrate the substrate 'im of
things in other words where things are
made of we caught mary ology and we
dismissed all that completely so we
disagree with with Aristotle here what
things are made of is not important what
we want to do is see the mechanisms that
these invisible things do how they do it
okay that's what we want to understand
we don't care what they're made oh yeah
what we care is what is the mechanism
it's like it's like saying I showed the
other day was it felix the cat breaking
the window right so you say how did the
window break well it broke because the
brick went through there or a horseshoe
or whatever and what Aristotle says here
is well let's look at what the horseshoe
is made out of let's look at what the
brick is made out we don't care that
doesn't that doesn't has nothing to do
with the mechanism of how the window
broke the mechanism or how the window
broke is straightforward brick goes
through there breaks it and breakers on
the ground and the glass is all
shattered we don't get
what is the glass may not it has all
these particles that is at sio2 is as
strong as that we we don't care about
any of that nonsense we just want to
know how the window broke and that
mechanism is brick goes through window
we're done that's it that's how
kindergarten ish it is and it's when you
get into all this stuff that is
unrelated that we get into trouble and
that was part of Aristotle's failure I
think anyways he said another account is
that nature is the shape or form which
is specified in the definition of the
thing which is very close to you no I
don't think you really had total grasp
of that he was not aware of what he said
but yeah we have what is the thing made
of and then it's form that's it those
are the things and and those are the
things that he exists and I guess he had
this notion also of see and touch maybe
in the back of his mind you know and
obviously they couldn't see the air so
that grows raised a lot of questions
they couldn't see gravity whatever
gravity was causing you know things the
stone to fall to the floor they couldn't
see that so they said you know they
couldn't figure that out at all you've
been close and then he says the
mathematician differs from the physicist
aha physical bodies contain surfaces and
volumes lines and points and these are
the subject matter of mathematics in
other words either's misses lines and
points per se as geometric objects and
he says you know that's that's the realm
of mathematics they like to talk about
volumes angles whether something is
perpendicular or parallel those that's
the subject matter of men though numbers
obviously does us that's the subject
matter of mathematics geometry
essentially which was a I think the
cradle of mathematics and it's not what
he's trying to do he's trying to
understand nature he's trying to
understand how things work mechanisms
causes
and that's why he begins at things that
exist and I think this is an important
point too just to start because you need
to keep those two sup you need to keep
the mathematician very far away from the
physicist and that's not what
mathematical physics does they try to do
the opposite they try to merge these in
Congress worlds math is a language and
physics is a science math is not a
science math is just a language and like
I was saying the other day as these
people the mathematical physicists are
trying to tell you that in order to
understand how this universe works you
need to understand Chinese you need to
take a very advanced course in Chinese
so I need to learn Chinese to understand
how this universe works yeah you do and
can't you translate it to English so
that I know how this universe works well
it's not a one-to-one correspondence I
can it's not literal a literal
translation and so we can't do it will
give you a ball perfect or a big
ballpark idea and that's when they come
in they say well you have this
four-dimensional space-time which is
unimaginable and the building ball
weighs down to the the fish net and
anything that falls in there's gravity
and that's that's our explanation so
yeah but hold it but time is is a
concept you're gonna Bend time well
that's why you need to learn Chinese
because I can't translate Chinese
directly into English and then go around
in circles they think that because they
have a language called mathematics that
you need to understand this descriptive
language in order to explain a mechanism
and that's absolutely not true
but that's the that's the notion people
have out there and so this is where it
all starts it starts with Aristotle
followed by Euclid Euclid goes into
geometry he essentially you can say lays
the foundations for mathematics even
though mathematics already existed
before that you know it came from way
back when and Aristotle he goes in a
different direction and he's trying to
figure out how this universe works and
then what you
obvious people throughout the ages we
talked about Aquinas st. Thomas Aquinas
he picks up from Aristotle he picks up
where Aristotle left off and tries to
figure out again what motion and
specifically time B's they're concerned
with time by this by this time by the
13th century they're concerned with time
and you know and mathematics of geometry
really takes off in the 17th century
when you know people like who against
and Newton like this these guys picked
up on that you know they develop it
further they invent the calculus and so
on down the line
and so they take their cues really from
the site of Euclid they're not
interested so much in understanding they
want to understand but you know they
touch upon Aristotle lightly they go
more with what they consider something
more organized more precise something
you can count on which is geometry which
is mathematics ok so that's it for today
what I'm gonna do is I'm going to
continue with this line I'm going to
continue with Aristotle analyzing a
little bit of this book compared against
Euclid's so that you can see the
contrast between how we started you know
the Greeks and you're gonna see a
contrast between Aristotle and nuclear
fission what they're trying to achieve
each one in his own realm and by the way
Euclid was more from the line of Plato
and Plato was a mystic he was a guy who
all the religious folk like st.
Augustine and even st. Thomas you know
all these people they they were platanus
Plato miss okay if they follow Plato
they they they liked a lot of the you
know shadowy stuff you know the real
thing is not the thing but the shadow of
the thing that sort of thing and so they
were they were mystics
and that's the line that Euclid is
really gonna go into because he goes
into all this abstraction of geometry
which is what we have today when you
when you look at geometry it's all
abstract and all mathematics is quite
abstract means it's all out there you
know in numbers and you just have to
look at relations all that is abstract
it has nothing to do with a real world
you know ball falling or you know seesaw
or all these physical things that we see
every day so one thing is that this
mathematical description another one is
the mechanism and its mechanisms which
died essentially with Aristotle okay so
we'll see you what is it on Sunday sorry
on Wednesday we'll see you on Wednesday
and we'll continue with this line of
thinking we'll see you there bye bye